hey everybody I'm grant from chefsteps
and today we're going to talk about the
science of serine stuff you know stuff
like meat things that are protein rich
are usually more delicious seared and a
lot of that's due to reaction called the
my yard reaction without them my yard
reaction you don't have tasty steak in a
tasty pork chop and you're never tasted
chicken some folks call it the Browning
reaction but really it's kind of the
flavor reaction it's responsible for
developing color aroma and flavor in
toast coffee pizza fried food beer nuts
brown butter Dolce de leche and even
suntan lotion it's true it's all my art
we're going to sear some chicken so this
chicken breast has a ton of protein all
over the surface of it and as soon as it
starts to heat up those amino acids turn
brown so what we're gonna do try to get
it a little bit flatter surface you know
all the skins I'm nice plain easy now
we're ready to see you salt is awesome
on chicken skin and all that stuff
because it's desiccant that pulls out
moisture and it promotes longer lasting
crisp in the skin or a surface later so
right now the chicken skin wants to
shrink but I'm not gonna let it press on
it don't worry about this rag it's not
on your chicken this is my chicken so
you can comment about your own rag
quality I'm gonna truth if it was round
I'd have just like a little strip of
Darkness here let's give me nice and
dark nice and crispy everywhere I'm
gonna eat that
[Music]
got salmon
I want more surface area on the salmon
so I'm gonna score it you open up the
skin gives you more Krispies and plus
the salt goes in there that makes it
extra flavorful
well don't drop stuff in towards you
drop it away because it likes to slap
the oil away from you towards the camera
guy lay it in the pan leave it alone a
big one for fish on the grill you like
sticking your burning I don't know why
people do that it was all just sticking
like as soon as they put it down like
yeah now it is the edges cook faster in
the middle but they tighten up and it
makes a little cut so you put the fish
down you press on it push the middle
down want to make sure it steers I like
to do probably like 75% of the Syrians
on the skin side and I'm waiting for
that little white line to get up to
almost past halfway oh it's perfect
crispy salmon skin is so good and then
the second side it only takes a couple
seconds and you let it rest in you're
done the wicked crispy skin
porkchop we've got a double-cut pork
chop what we're gonna do differently
with this guy is start by searing all
this beautiful fat and it goes from
chewy to crispy if you're going for dark
and crispy you're not gonna get that
deep dark crust until the waters gone so
you can give it a head start by blotting
it salt oil we're gonna end up with even
more oil because all this fats is going
to render so start fat side down it's a
serious Syrian uh if you're gonna do it
do it right that's what my dad used to
yell at me tada
it's a golden pork chop you'll notice
I've rotated this one a lot and played
with this one a lot because I'm nervous
I'm kidding I've always found pork chops
I'm always moving them around rotating
them to get a nice golden sear
that is my our Deen everywhere
janna smells super good too well dude
hey can you dude we are getting some
good sears today guys we've got the big
boy the steak this is like the ultimate
way to see your steak you got like a hot
date and you don't want to screw it up
you bought the good meat tonight
compressed your date salt salt don't be
all scared of the salt but more than you
think it needs I love lots of garlic
I don't worry about picking the paper
for this just give it a smash papers
gonna kind of fall off a little bit
later it doesn't really matter a little
dorky here with the pepper I like roasty
seared pepper flavor
so there's a couple stages to what we're
gonna do here we're gonna sear it just a
little bit on each side and then we're
gonna baste
first I'm gonna flip it got a little bit
us here you see how this is dark red and
caramel a big gray spot all wet and
soggy great spot great thought grace
well that's because the protein is
coming up and it's steamy put the butter
in yet
be patient grasshopper
the garlic's gonna get some my art to
all this fat I want to sear that and get
some color and render that renders a
Chevy word it just means like milk like
roasty my Artie's back to butter how
much should I put in one two three three
butters okay here's what I do if I have
garlic I keep them towards the front of
the pan here cuz that's where it pulls
up and then face you can tell your hot
date you've done it a thousand times
there's no big deal this will cook the
steak really fast
you're almost deep-frying it just do
this for a minute or so dude look at
this that is good-looking beef
[Music]
whoa that's good that's a good piece of
meat but it's got a ton of flavor from
all that delicious to my arc reactor oh
[Music]
that's embarrassing okay
[Music]
you